we also need to rescue the present for
the future and here you will recognize
Brewster Kahle sorry Brewster he's
sitting in the front seat another local
hero who who has an exemplary kind of
archive the Internet Archive technology
allows people now to become their own
archivists what they're lacking is in
fact a robust backup system but because
of something like the Internet Archive
people are able to identify what is
valuable to them and upload it onto the
archive to be preserved
I say coyly it people are able to do
this on institutions like the Internet
Archive but I think many of us know that
the Internet Archive is unique and that
I think at least the real business of
libraries and archives is to replicate
something like the Internet Archive to
be able to make it possible to upload
people's memories as it were the things
that they value and preserve them for
the long term we can talk more about
that at the break or in in QA one last
thing I want to say about Thomas
Jefferson before I wind up is that one
of the things that's so instructive
about Jefferson library is that he
collected everything that he thought it
took to create this new being the
American citizen and he thought it was
very important to have everything about
America but also to have everything that
recorded all the virtues and all the
vice of men and his book his libraries
were full of books with written by
people that he strenuously disagreed
with for example Hume he couldn't stand
Hume the Tory but he kept that because
he thought that people needed to be able
to know about everything that humans
thought and be able to judge for
themselves I want to say to me the
greatest threat to memory going forward
is that we would create in a knowledge
monoculture in which all the stuff that
we think is correct that we agree with
gets saved and I think we're real hazard
of doing this everyone can say yes this
would be true of China or you know the
Soviet Union when it gets reincarnated
in Russia that of course they want a
censor the past
but I think we do it too in our liberal
democracy committed to scientific
knowledge trumping all other kinds of
knowledge that we only that we always
privilege some kinds of knowledge over
others and I just want to point out to
that to the wonderful biological truth
that there is no such thing as a fixed
perfect being that a being is the one
that adjusts most rapidly to a changing
environment so that mammals they didn't
evolve legs so they could walk on earth
they actually had these wing leg like
accoutrements these kind of you know mal
adaptations that when they were forced
to land on land they could actually
recruit to become legs and so they
survived these are called exaptation 's
and i think of that all the superseded
information that we have in our
libraries as these cultural acceptations
we all mourn the loss of the Library of
Alexandria but you know it wasn't lost
in war it was lost it was allowed to
perish because first the Christian
Emperor's and later the Islamic
caliphate decided that it was full of
pagan learning which had no value for
the future and so they had no interest
in keeping it around but without the
recovery the excavation of that
knowledge during the Renaissance and
Reformation we would not have what we
have today we certainly wouldn't have
rediscovered the Greeks and the Romans
we wouldn't understand democracy and we
certainly wouldn't have the foundational
foundations for scientific thinking that
we have so I think our own kind of
temporal chauvinism poses a very great
risk for us right now our sort of
intellectual arrogance that because
we're we're knowledgeable in scientific
about things that we actually know more
about the then those people in the past
we don't
[Music]
you